Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
nuestro invitado de hoy es el Primer
Ministro de Palestina Mohamed stayet
Muchas gracias por estar con nosotros
Gracias por recibirme señores taller hay
un nuevo gobierno israelí quizás el
gobierno más derechista en la historia
de Israel
esto significa que ha llegado el fin de
la solución de dos estados tal como lo
conocemos
Bueno desde luego todo el programa de
asentamiento se diseñó para destruir la
solución de dos estados
y los asentamientos no han sido
construidos durante el mandato de este
gobierno pero lo que habrá ahora es una
erosión total de las fronteras de 1967
habrá un método agresivo para la
colonización a través de la
intensificación de los programas de
colonización
y ahora también lo que ellos llaman la
legalización de más de 85 asentamientos
nuevos en cisjordania y alrededor de
Jerusalén
desde luego este gobierno como usted
bien dijo No sólo es radical sino que
También incluye personas que han sido
acusadas de delitos penales
algunos ministros y además varios
miembros del acnézet elegidos hace poco
son en realidad colonos sí es un grupo
de radicales Pero además algunas
personas han sido acusadas de corrupción
algunas personas han sido acusadas de
actos delictivos y demás y por supuesto
el objetivo de este gobierno es acabar
con el asunto de una vez por todas
Usted cree que lo que quieren es la
anexión
sí creo que quieren la anexión pero para
nosotros cada uno de los asentamientos
es una propuesta de alección
estas personas expresan fuerte y claro
sus intenciones
fue designado como el responsable del
área de Galilea y de cisjordania esto
significa que hay una erosión completa
de las fronteras de 1967 pero aún así
los dos estados están ahí
si no nos encargamos de esto mañana
pasado mañana será demasiado tarde
algunos de los ministros han dicho que
ya no quieren a la autoridad Palestina
cree que hay literalmente una amenaza
existencial sobre Su autoridad Palestina
en primer lugar la autoridad Palestina
no es un regalo que nos hicieron los
israelíes
no es un regalo de la comunidad
internacional es algo que hemos logrado
con nuestro sacrificios
en segundo lugar tiene razón se ha
lanzado una guerra contra nosotros una
guerra por la Tierra y la geografía la
guerra por la gente la demografía una
guerra por la narrativa y una guerra por
las finanzas de la autoridad Palestina
que nos está poniendo en una situación
difícil
cerca de la quiebra no realmente pero no
hemos podido pagar salarios completos en
los últimos tres o cuatro meses
Sencillamente por los israelíes y por
las deducciones legales de nuestras
finanzas Israel está deduciendo más de
250 millones de cheques cada mes lo que
nos está poniendo en una situación
financiera muy difícil ahora Estamos
aquí en Europa está entrando un dinero y
también está entrando un dinero
proveniente de Países Árabes no de todos
pero creo que lograremos superar esto
porque nuestro pueblo ha mostrado
resiliencia resistencia y tolerancia en
general las personas han sido muy
comprensivas de la situación financiera
en la que nos encontramos
concretamente hay pasos sobre los que
usted ya ha hablado en el pasado como
renunciar los acuerdos de oslo
detener la coordinación de la seguridad
con Israel eso es algo que la autoridad
Palestina está considerando
sí
es algo que los dirigentes palestinos
están considerando y creo que si este
gobierno israelí que usa algunas líneas
rojas
no tenemos más opción que ir en esa
dirección no solo es eso Cuáles son esas
líneas rojas porque ha hecho amenazas
antes pero nunca ha pasado nada tiene
razón pero hemos tomado decisiones el
consejo central palestino ha decidido
que iremos En esa dirección
además los dirigentes palestinos han
decidido escoger el momento oportuno
ahora por supuesto si este gobierno
continúa con los asesinatos con los
asentamientos
con la irrupción en la mezquita de Alexa
con la colonización e intensificación de
los programas de colonización
rojas pero también la acumulación misma
de una línea roja ahora la Corte
Internacional de Justicia dará una
opinión consultiva los israelíes han
estado afirmando que la ocupación
israelí es temporal ahora la corte dirá
parece que está ocupación no es temporal
que será permanente y por lo tanto se le
pedirá a la comunidad internacional que
vea la situación desde una perspectiva
totalmente distinta desde luego este
gobierno israelí ya está cruzando las
líneas rojas las amenazas a hannahmar la
erupción en la mezquita como lo dije
antes el anuncio a la legalización de 85
asentamientos
por nuestra parte nos encaminamos a no
seguir viviendo con el status
el estatus quo es insostenible es
intolerable y creo que debemos romper
con el status quo de manera realista
porque podría anunciar que detendrá la
coordinación de seguridad con Israel en
los próximos meses
los dirigentes palestinos hablado acerca
de un paquete de medidas entre las que
se incluye continuar con la coordinación
de seguridad
Esto es algo que no podremos mantener
porque pagar una seguridad en la que no
se recibe algo político a cambio es un
ejercicio inútil
y por lo tanto es algo que se está
considerando es cuestión de tiempo
usted está aquí en Europa se reunió con
los ministros de asuntos exteriores de
la Unión Europea con el jefe de política
exterior de la Unión Europea le ha
estado pidiendo a los países europeos no
solo que hablen acerca de la solución de
dos estados que vuelvan a la mesa de
negociación porque ya no hay mesa de
negociación también les ha pedido que
reconozcan a Palestina Pero eso no está
dando resultado Por qué hay nueve países
europeos que sí reconocen a Palestina
como estado según las fronteras de 1967
con Jerusalén como su capital incluido
Suecia y otros países europeos pero
ninguno nuevo ninguno nuevo pero hemos
que hablando con los ministros y asuntos
exteriores y dijimos miren todos ustedes
creen en los dos estados y todos hablan
de los dos estados realmente lo creen yo
creo que sí creo que cada capital
europea realmente cree en los dos
estados La pregunta es qué hacemos para
preservar la solución de dos estados en
un momento en el que Israel está
sistemáticamente destruyendo los dos
estados Ese es el verdadero reto para la
comunidad internacional que
efectivamente cree en la solución de dos
estados en particular Europa y también
Estados Unidos cuando el presidente
biden nos visitó en Belén dijo
explícitamente que él realmente cree en
los dos estados según las fronteras de
1967 lo dijo fuerte y claro fue muy
específico sobre esta cuestión el
verdadero problema para Washington y
para todos nosotros para Europa y para
los Países Árabes es que hacer para
preservar esa solución de dos estados
para nosotros o bien castigan a Israel
por lo que hace para destruir estados
sanciones porque Israel está violando la
ley internacional
Israel está violando los Derechos
Humanos Israel en realidad Está
construyendo colonias en contra de la
ley internacional entonces Ustedes deben
aplicar sanciones porque la ocupación
israelí debería costarle a Israel y
debería tener un precio actualmente la
ocupación Israel y progresa eso por un
lado por otro es que envíen un mensaje a
los israelíes diciendo miren reconocemos
a Palestina como un estado según sus
fronteras de 1967 con Jerusalén como su
capital Estas son las dos medidas que
pueden preservar la solución de dos
estados y enviarle un mensaje claro a
este gobierno israelí por supuesto usted
mencionó a Estados Unidos El consejero
de seguridad nacional acaba de estar en
Israel y Palestina Anthony blink en el
secretario de estado tiene programado
una visita como acaba de decir Ha oído a
Joe biden decir cosas buenas Pero qué
pasa con las acciones con los hechos
prometieron abrir el consulado de
Estados Unidos en Jerusalén Este pero no
se está haciendo probablemente no se
hará la misión de la olp en Washington
quiero decir no está decepcionado por el
balance de administración biden después
de años de Trump
mire tuvimos mucha esperanza cuando
eligieron al presidente biden Ya esa
administración durante su campaña
dijeron muchas cosas buenas en la
llamada entre el presidente abad y el
presidente biden el presidente biden
también dijo cosas muy buenas durante su
viaje a Palestina en Belén repitió las
mismas cosas en realidad no se ha
implementado nada de lo que prometió lo
único que Estados Unidos está siendo es
volver a darle fondos a la agencia de la
ONU para los refugiados palestinos que
es muy importante para nosotros pero
hablaron sobre acciones unilaterales
hablaron sobre mantener el status quo
dejará mal sharif hablaron sobre
asentamientos hablaron sobre financiar a
la autoridad Palestina hablaron sobre
acciones unilaterales hablaron sobre
volver a abrir el consulado
estadounidense Jerusalén que el
presidente Trump cerró después de que
estuviera abierto desde hace 110 años
eso no se ha materializado esperemos que
lo hagan les están mintiendo
No digo que estén mintiendo creo que no
lo harán creo que es una gran decepción
y pienso que el mensaje que les
enviaremos es miren no nos Pongan en una
situación incómoda si acudimos a la
Corte Penal Internacional se molestan
sacudimos a la Corte Internacional de
Justicia se molestan y hacen lo bien
contra nuestra nosotros estamos tomando
medidas pacíficas para que la voz de los
palestinos se oiga fuerte y Clara en
todos los foros internacionales entonces
o bien Estados Unidos utiliza la ventaja
que tiene con Israel y trata de detener
la destrucción de los dos estados
o Seguiremos con nuestras medidas que
incluyen la internacionalización del
conflicto
que incluyen las medidas sobre las que
ha estado hablando el consejo central
palestino eso es lo que le hemos dicho a
los estadounidenses pero no están
escuchando es muy desafortunado que no
hayamos visto una toma seria de medidas
por supuesto los estadounidenses tratan
de mantener la situación en silencio Se
están hablando de la situación pero no
están encontrando soluciones y creo que
ese es un problema muy serio y que
necesitamos a Washington pero no solo se
trata de que Washington esté ausente de
esta arena política
Nosotros también somos Víctimas de la
crisis en Ucrania
Porque ahora el Cuarteto está muerto y
hay un vacío político además francamente
el presidente estadounidense es el único
presidente de Estados Unidos de los
últimos años
que no ha pensado en un plan de paz o en
una iniciativa
la administración estadounidense ni
siquiera nombró un enviado para la paz
Entonces no le están prestando toda su
atención al conflicto está bien
quizás de nuestro lado debemos repensar
las cosas
entonces tengamos que presionar
seriamente a los israelíes y a los
estadounidenses para que nos tomen muy
en serio pero
la alternativa es una tercera enfada qué
tan probable es esto si la situación
permanece en un punto muerto como lo
acaba de describir
desde luego el pueblo palestino está
molesto el pueblo palestino está muy
decepcionado
y además francamente la rabia Palestina
viene del hecho de que la comunidad
internacional tiene una doble moral
people ONU mire lo que está pasando en
Ucrania
la manera en la que manejan la cuestión
de Ucrania es una cosa
la manera en la que maneja la ocupación
israelí en Palestina es totalmente
distinta
sabemos que Ucrania le está tocando la
puerta a todos los europeos eso es
cierto pero nosotros también somos
vecinos estamos en el mismo mediterráneo
somos vecinos de Europa y todas las
crisis en Palestina se reflejan
directamente ni un solo palestino está
con el grupo estado islámico ni un solo
palestino está involucrado en ningún
acto terrorista en el mundo ahora
Estamos trabajando duro para tratar de
lograr la paz y la justicia a través de
medios pacíficos y obviamente en la
comunidad internacional algunos escuchan
otros
hay otro problema desde hace algunos
años Usted lo ha descrito como una
puñalada por la espalda varios Países
Árabes han entablado relaciones con
Israel claramente esto Quizás esté
mandando un mensaje de que causa
Palestina no es central ni siquiera para
los Países Árabes
al contrario vimos al presidente biden
en read todos los líderes árabes han
hablado sobre Palestina sobre la
centralidad de la cuestión Palestina
mire por ejemplo el ministro de asuntos
exteriores de Arabia Saudita dijo
explícitamente en davos
si no se resuelve el problema palestino
sin la creación del estado de Palestina
no habrá una normalización saudí con
Israel Confía en que no cambiarán su
posición sí confiamos en los audios
confiamos en ellos son muy claros hablan
fuerte claro Nosotros también estamos
Estableciendo un diálogo muy serio con
Arabia Saudita y confiamos en Arabia
Saudita de la misma manera en que
confiamos en otros países árabes
actualmente el problema con el gobierno
israelí es que no es un Aliado Ese es el
mayor problema en un momento en el que
el presidente Avast es un Aliado en el
que nosotros somos aliados de la
comunidad internacional
pero Israel no es un Aliado en Israel
hay algo muy distinto destrucción en vez
de construcción
última pregunta hay otro problema que
está debilitando las causas palestinas
la división con jamás no voy a ser cruel
y contar la cantidad de reuniones donde
se han proclamado la reconciliación y el
sí es el fin no ha ocurrido nada señor
Primer Ministro Por qué sigue pasando
esto
Ahora el presidente abas ha hecho un
llamado al diálogo palestino
y creo que tomaremos esa dirección para
acabar con la división
y llegaron gobierno palestino unitario
mohamath Muchas gracias por estar en la
entrevista de France 24 desde Bruselas y
muchas gracias a ustedes por su sintonía
[Música]